Tom Hanks in castaway gets a volleyball
Chris Pratt and passengers against
Jennifer Lawrence just then one of them
wins passengers so passengers takes
place on board a ship called the Avalon
that's going through deep space to
another world they're gonna colonize
this other planet the entire crew is in
cryo sleep for about a hundred and
twenty years after 30 of those 120 years
90 years too soon Chris Pratt's
character gets woken up from cryo sleep
for reasons unknown then sometime after
that Jennifer Lawrence's character gets
woken up and then later on down the
movie the ship starts malfunctioning
it's in you know thriller stuff which is
funny it really breaks this movie up
into three sections the first section
Chris Pratt gets woken up it really is
one dude in isolation hanging out is
castaway in space yes no interaction
will except Michael Sheen who's this
Android bartender I thought it was great
but it was cool seeing this dude at
first he's all confused he tries to find
solutions to his problem he just kind of
hangs out eats all the fine food and
starts to livin it up on the ship
because he's like there are no rules
what's anyone gonna do then Jennifer
Lawrence's character comes into the
scene then it becomes a romance that's
not quite as interesting as the segment
where Chris Pratt was just isolated and
alone which really made me wonder
whether or not Jennifer Lawrence's
character was necessary to begin with
but what's wrong with a space movie
about isolation that's just that's
interesting enough a box office however
admittedly there is a neat moral dilemma
that Chris Pratt does face in this movie
it has to do with that element I thought
that was actually really cool and then
you know the thriller stuff which goes
down exactly how you think is gonna go
down it really does what I liked is
Chris Pratt really carries a lot of this
movie he really does he's just his
character is more interesting character
than Jennifer Lawrence's character he
has more layers than she has something
she's bad she's Jennifer Lawrence she'll
love it or hate it depending on how you
feel about that statement but it is what
it is but what we have here is a
Frankenstein of three genres among the
sci-fi genre its sci-fi drama sci fi
real man sci fi thriller it's nothing
you haven't seen before a lot of things
in this movie is nothing you haven't
seen before the movie slow what do you
want it's this kind of slow his movies
like cornflakes it's the cornflakes of
cereals like is it bad now
is it good well its cornflakes not sweet
it doesn't have any real distinguished
food flavor to a couple people hanging
out even when they try to throw drama in
there it's not as interesting is they
want it to be for you I guess
that's a big gripe about the movie is
there are opportunities there are
moments where you like you could have
done something interesting with that you
could have done something really
interesting with that do they not really
and that you just look at what could
have been in the movie that is
passengers look this is a simple review
for a simple movie in the end passengers
was okay I really liked a couple of
elements in here that I can't really
talk about because it's kind of spoiler
ish and really the backbone of this
movie is the romance column and it's one
of the weaker parts of this film some of
you out there will enjoy passengers some
won't I can't quite get it to ya you
should watch passengers was on the
fringe but right now as I stand I will
say passengers would have been a better
time if I were drunk yeah now it's a
party along with Jennifer lunch you
kidding me the best thing ever
keya alright guys so passengers have you
seen it what did you think about it or
was your favorite sci-fi drama out there
whatever you think whatever it is
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you